we spent a lot of time in the cold war
alpha playing combined arms which is the
closest equivalent to modern warfare's
ground war mode there's some
fundamentally different things that we
need to talk about
in this video we're gonna see which of
the larger game modes seems to have the
advantage right now
but keep in mind that cold war is an
alpha the purpose of an alpha is to
shake out bugs and make tweaks before
the final release in november
at the highest level when we're looking
at cold war's combined arms mode versus
modern warfare's groundwarm mode
there seems to be two competing design
philosophies cold war's larger maps
still lean towards more traditional and
finely crafted
call of duty design it gives players a
sense of consistency and fairness and
rewards map memorization through
predictable routes
modern warfare went in the other
direction with sandbox design
where players can wind up parachuting
just about any darn place and experiment
with combinations of things at the risk
of sometimes
breaking the game in that regard let's
start with players ability to make
decisions that impact a match
i'm talking about spawning in modern
warfare's ground war mode you can choose
to spawn at a captured objective or on
your squad
sometimes it doesn't work and you do get
spawn killed but overall it allows for a
level of coordination
and strategic thinking around objectives
the most common of which is establishing
a spawn behind enemy lines and then
pinching the enemy team at the middle
in cold war's combined arms alpha you
couldn't pick a spawn point
at all this isn't a problem on
traditional small three-lane maps
but on larger ones with objectives all
over the place it just gets chaotic
you're constantly spawning in
unpredictable places or being kicked to
the back of the map entirely
that means longer runs to objectives
fewer engagements
and it hampers your ability to push an
objective multiple times in a row
it also slows down the pacing of matches
on armada where you sometimes spawn
inside of ships it can be disorienting
and take a minute to figure out where
you are
feeding into the slower pacing of the
12v12 player count versus groundwars 32
32 combined arms maps are too small for
a massive player boost
but it could come up just a bit for more
consistent action for now we're giving
this one to modern warfare's ground war
and hope the final version of combined
arms lets you choose a spawn point
next let's talk about vehicle and
infantry balance cold war's made some
interesting choices here
with the right create a class build
namely an lmg vehicle damage attachment
and engineering perk
it's pretty easy to destroy enemy tanks
and gun boats when fighting boats you
can dive all the way underwater where
they just can't see you
with tanks you can cheese them through
some of the railings and objects in the
game
on the flip side whenever we got in a
tank or a boat we did a lot of damage
because in our experience a lot of cold
war players didn't learn to build
anti-vehicle loadouts yet
in modern warfare rockets are pretty
common in ground war
so to help the average player out
combined arms has heavy machine guns
scattered around the map
they're in a fixed location though so if
you're a savvy tank driver they're
pretty easy to deal with
the other thing players have is the
sigma 2 rocket launcher it's high rate
of fire but low damage
and also only has two rockets so it's
mostly just good for knocking out uavs
because of all this we're guessing one
group of players is going to come out of
this alpha saying vehicles are too
powerful
and the other side is going to say
they're too weak to be honest this one
feels like a tie with ground war
they're powerful if you stay on the move
and also easily destroyed if you know
what you're doing
what's more important in our opinion is
something else it's for both games to
award as much experience
and general unlocks for using vehicles
as using guns or else call of duty
players tend to avoid vehicles
altogether to grind gun attachments
full disclosure there was no unlock tree
in the cold war alpha
when it comes to playing objectives and
combined arms we need to talk about
score streaks
we initially thought that score streaks
were very different from modern
warfare's kill streaks but in practice
in this alpha they were oddly similar
youtubers are reporting that to get the
high end score streaks you still need to
make a chain of kills to earn the right
multipliers and that going and capturing
objectives doesn't get you there
in fact it's counterproductive as it
stands cold war's combined arms mode
does not reward support play styles
enough
and we'd like to see scorestreak
multipliers for capturing objectives
increased we did find playing objectives
consistently got you the low end score
streaks
for folks who are worried about that
making high-end score streaks even
easier for top end players
we could tie those to the percentage of
objectives captured which is unique to
combine arms and a big improvement over
modern warfare system
we definitely need to play and test
these systems more for ourself to make
any kind of final conclusion
and how you feel will really depend on
if you like to play support or just
chase those kills
next let's talk about map creativity and
the idea of the sandbox
i'll just be upfront that it's tough to
compare ground war with combined arms
here due to different design
philosophies
there are pros and cons on both sides i
have to start by saying the way modern
warfare familiarizes players with
locations
using the overworld map is absolutely
genius and something we can't recall
seeing in a multiplayer shooter before
the overworld map is made up of all the
smaller maps and you'll see the same
locations over and over again across
multiple modes in warzone for example
you'll land on a ground war map and know
exactly where everything is
now the flip side of that is that
familiarity comes at a cost
there aren't any straight up bonkers
ground war maps like cold war's armada
armada is entirely sea based and has so
much potential
for starters you can spend the entire
match in the water you can swim under
everything
there's no equivalent in groundwater
seeing helicopters and boats explode and
sink into the depths with sharks
circling nearby
that being said armada still doesn't
feel as free as ground war sandbox
it has a fixed flow between objectives
with zip lines and fast rubs you're
never gonna
parachute to or find unexpected routes
after a few rounds like you do in ground
war
for example there's this one really cool
shipping container you can snipe from
but it's meticulously balanced sight
lines means you're never going to be
able to hold up there
between the two cold war might actually
have a little bit more room here to
experiment with wild settings
okay so speaking of maps let's touch on
polish i can't stress enough that
combined arms was an alpha and we didn't
expect it to be the finished build of
the game
that being said the combined arms alpha
had a few things to learn from mistakes
that even ground war still makes
this will be a bit of a grab bag of
things let's start with how players are
indicated
mainly health bars in cold war players
have these giant health bars over their
heads that can both obstruct the view of
what's behind them and give away their
position a bit too easily
plus it kind of pulls you out of the
immersion may just be an alpha thing
kind of hoping they're not in the final
build though all the enough ground war
has had similar problems with player
icons being too bright
it's common to see a friendly player's
icon across the map line up with an
enemy soldier running right at you
and mistake them for friendly neither
game has mastered player icons yet
next both combined arms and ground war
are bad at communicating what players
can and can't shoot
through on the armada map for example we
couldn't shoot players through a
staircase that we could clearly see
through
in ground war you can shoot through
metal on one map but not on another
neither game has a clear visual
indicator of what objects stop bullets
when it comes to physics on the armada
map the underwater game is a bit rough
with throwables accelerating oddly
scorestreaks detonating at the bottom of
the ocean like the water doesn't exist
and the probably intentional but
immersion breaking ability to fire
rockets and snipe from underwater
groundware also has its struggles with
physics with issues like helicopters
being taken out of the game on several
occasions
for game breaking bugs how are you
feeling about cold war so far and its
larger multiplayer mode combined arms
let us know your thoughts in the
comments below we are really looking
forward to seeing their
next large mode called fireteam that
pits 10 teams of four against each other
to battle on a map
and complete objectives stay tuned to
gamespot.com for more call of duty black
ops cold war coverage
and thanks for watching
you